[Music]
dude this dream i had last night i
almost want to
write and shoot as a scene because it
was so
crazy
i i'm in a bathroom at a wawa okay
already bed yeah
i go in
and i'm walking up to the bathroom i
hear the screaming it's like come on man
come on
i go inside and there's a dude reaching
over the top of a stall giving another
guy a wedgie like as tall as the
stall like he's a it's a tall ass dude
and he's just ripping this dude's
underwear out of his ass and the dude's
screaming like for a dear life like come
on man let it go let it go and i turn
around i'm like [ __ ] i don't
i need to pee though
so i go in i'm like i'm not a [ __ ] and
i go in and i go pee
and the stalling into there's no toilet
it's just
the like the pipe where the toilet would
be so it's like a hole
i'm like i'm not gonna complain i'm just
piss piss right into the drain i can do
it so i start peeing in the hole and as
i'm peeing in the hole there's a
someone from the stall
next to me is pissing on my shoe okay
like being funny i'm like
god damn it
so i walk out of the stall
and there's a dude waiting there with
like an assassin's creed knife it's like
wrapped around his wrist and it's like
sticking like out from underneath his
hand and he grabs me he's like hold on
bro i'm like what how is he peeing huh
no he wasn't the peeing one he wasn't
the peeing he was just waiting outside
the stall
and then so then the dude who peed on my
shoe he walks out of the stall and he's
like a shot caller he like zips up his
pants and he like looks at me and he
like looks at the guy and he's like do
it
and then he's like him i'm like what the
[ __ ]
i'm like what did i do it's fine it's
mine these shoes weren't that expensive
anyways
i'm scared i'm scared
i'm scared
and so they start like talking to each
other and they get distracted and i use
that as my opportunity to [ __ ] bolt
i run
and then they come out of the stall and
it's three of them
and
i forget what i'm standing outside the
bathroom with they're like these two
people are supposed to be my friends or
some [ __ ]
and it was like some video game thing
where they came out and they're like do
you see that [ __ ] and i just
looked away
and they just kind of you know just left
me alone like some npc behavior
and i woke up thinking dude did i just
get my shoe peed on and almost stabbed
that was crazy that's a wild dream i
know it's just like
you